foreign
[Music]
and thank you for joining us for today's
webinar it's the Statin C and Race Free
GFR estimation evaluating both clinical
guidelines and laboratory perspectives
on more widespread implementation
sponsored by Siemens health and ears I
am Kaylee Bach of labyrinths and I'll be
your moderator for today's session
we have two key experts speaking today
on different aspects of sustatan c and
evaluating glomerular filtration rates
of the kidneys
I hope you will also find the content to
be informative interesting and useful
now before we start a few items that I
would like to bring to your attention
any questions or thoughts you might have
can be submitted during the presentation
into the Q a box found on the bottom
left hand side of your screen
we will try our best to address those
questions and comments during the Q a
portion of the webinar as time permits
in the event we're unable to address
your question or comment during the Q a
we will be sure to follow up promptly by
email after the webinar
if you have any questions or experience
any technical challenges related to the
platform please utilize the Q a box to
submit your request and someone will be
able to assist you
recently use of algorithms that alter
patient medical care based on race has
fallen under increasing criticism as
race-based medicine has been shown to
contribute to healthcare disparities
in response to the National Kidney
Foundation an American Society of
nephrology formed the task force on
reassessing the inclusion of race and
diagnosing kidney diseases
one of the preliminary recommendations
of the final report published September
of 2021 was to facilitate increased
routine and timely use of Statin C
as egfr based onto satin sea alone has
never relied on a race parameter to
estimate GFR
given recommendations by task force to
increase the use of the Statin C two key
perspectives are discussed the first
current state of sustatancy assay
performance and standardization as well
as barriers and potential strategies to
Aid in more widespread implementation of
satin C testing in clinical laboratories
and second describe the origins and
consequences of race-based estimated
glomerular filtration
our learning objectives for today are to
understand the importance of accurate
GFR estimates in evaluating patient
kidney function
describe the origins and consequences of
a race-based estimated glomerular
filtration
discuss the sentences role in
nkfasn Task Force guidelines
recommending race-free GFR estimation
and lastly to identify strategies and
expand implementation of Staten seed
testing in clinical labs for egfr
with that I'd like to welcome our first
Speaker Dr Amy Karger
director of the central laboratory for
the CKD Epi research group since 2015
and therefore has expertise on the
measurement of filtration markers
including creatinine sistatin C beta 2
microglobulin and beta Trace protein Dr
kargar is a recognized leader in the
field of laboratory medicine currently
serving in leadership roles with both
the College of American Pathologists and
the American Association of clinical
chemistry and is the vice president and
chair of the credentials committee for
the American Board of clinical chemistry
Dr Karger has extensive experience
directing or co-directing Central
Laboratory Testing for large clinical
trials and multi-institutional research
studies including the preventing early
renal loss and diabetes study and the
epidemiology of diabetes interventions
and complications study
Dr Karger you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much for this opportunity
to speak today and for that very kind
introduction
so today I'm going to discuss the Statin
C and Race 3 GFR estimation and provide
a Clinical Laboratory perspective on
implementing more widespread use of this
biomarker
and before I dive into my talk I did
want to share my disclosures
I have research support or has had
research support from Siemens Healthcare
Diagnostics and Kiowa Kirin
pharmaceutical development I've served
as an external consultant for Roche
Diagnostics and I've received speaker
honoraria from Siemens Healthcare
Diagnostics the National Kidney
Foundation and the American Kidney fund
and then lastly I serve as director of
the central laboratory for the CKD Fe
research group and we'll be presenting
some data from that research group today
foreign
objectives are shown here
today I will describe the origins and
consequences of race-based estimated GFR
reporting
discuss the statency's role in Race 3
GFR estimation based on the new nks ASN
Task Force guidelines
describe the current state of systatency
assay performance and standardization
and enclosed by identifying the barriers
to widespread system C testing and the
strategies to overcome these barriers
I want to start briefly with some
history on the origins of estimating
kidney function based on race as that
will provide the background for
understanding how we got to where we are
today with GFR estimating equations
primary means to assess kidney function
is to determine the glomerular
filtration rate or GFR
GFR is a measure of how well the kidneys
are filtering the blood which removes
waste products and extra fluid to
produce urine
Studies have demonstrated that the GFR
correlates well with other functions of
the kidney
and therefore is the best means for
assessing the overall health of the
kidney
GFR can be either directly measured or
it can be estimated
direct measurement is performed by
measuring the plasma or urinary
clearance of an exogenous filtration
marker that's injected into the patient
ideally this exogenous filtration marker
would be filtered by the glomerulus into
the tubule and not secreted or
reabsorbed by the tubules so that the
amount found in the urine reflects the
rate of glomerular filtration only
now while direct measurement of GFR is
considered the gold standard
it is an expensive and time-intensive
procedure and therefore is not commonly
done
instead estimation of the GFR is what is
routinely done for clinical care
GFR estimation is based on calculations
which incorporate measurement of
endogenous filtration markers namely
creatinine or cystatin C along with
demographic parameters to estimate the
GFR
in regards to GFR estimation I want to
review the history of the equations and
specifically describe when and why a
race parameter was incorporated into
these equations
race was first incorporated into GFR
equations in 1999 with the development
of the modification of diet and renal
disease or mdrd creatinine based
equation
the mdrd equation was the first egfr
equation that was widely reported by
clinical laboratories alongside the
creatinine result
the mdrd equation was the first to
include a correction factor for
African-American race
in 2009
chronic kidney disease epidemiology
collaboration or cktfe research group
developed in the updated creatinine
based equation called the CKD Epi
equation
this equation was determined to be more
accurate than the mdrd equation
particularly for individuals with egfr
greater than or equal to 60.
we create an equation retained a race
correction factor for African Americans
and lastly in 2012 the CKD Epi group
published two new equations that
incorporated the use of a new biomarker
versus Statin C
one of the equations was called the ckdf
thesis.in C equation and the other was
the combined ckdfe Korean and system C
equation
the equation based on substancy alone
did not include a race correction factor
as the Statin C had not been observed to
vary among race groups
on the other hand the combined
creatinine substantity equation did
retain a race correction factor because
that equation utilized creatinine which
had been observed to vary by race
so ultimately why was a race correction
factor initially incorporated into these
equations
at the time of the mdrd equation
development recruitment of a racially
diverse cohort into the mdrd study was
viewed as an advance in racial equity
and inclusion as many research studies
had predominantly white cohorts
incorporation of a race coefficient was
additionally viewed as an attempt to
improve and tailor Medical Care to
African Americans based on the observed
differences in creatinine levels between
the white and black cohorts in the mdrd
study
this rate correction was justified at
the time by a hypothesis that
African-American individuals released
more creatinine into the blood due to a
higher muscle mass on average than their
non-hispanic white counterparts
however data supporting that hypothesis
at the time was limited and in fact many
years later in 2008 stew it all
rigorously examined this hypothesis and
found no evidence that muscle mass or
nutritional status explain differences
in serum creatinine concentrations
between African-American and
non-african-american individuals
additionally since then genetic Studies
have confirmed that race is not a
biological construct but rather is a
social and subjective construct and
therefore should not be used to alter
medical care for patients
so what impact has the race correction
factor had
many Studies have reported on the
disparities in care for African-American
kidney disease patients
specifically African Americans have
declined in GFR at an earlier age and at
a faster annualized rate than
non-hispanic white Americans and they
also develop Advanced kidney disease at
younger ages with an incidence of
end-stage kidney disease approximately
three times higher than non-hispanic
white counterparts
despite this they are more likely to
receive a late referral to Nephrology
and less likely to be treated with home
dialysis Therapies
they are also less likely to be wait
listed for kidney transplant and are
transplanted at lower rates than their
non-hispanic white counterparts
these disparities are compounded by the
use of a race correction factor to
estimate GFR which increases the
estimated GFR for African-American
patients for a given creatinine level
so the equations make the
African-American patients egfr appear
better than their non-african-american
counterparts
foreign
these concerns about the impact of race
corruption in contributing to Health
Care disparities is what led to the
development of new guidelines
recommending race-free GFR estimation
I will briefly review the process
undertaken to develop these new
guidelines and then highlight the role
of the Statin C in these new
recommendations
over the last few years there have been
increasing calls to remove race from GFR
estimating equations do they due to the
issues I previously highlighted
disparities in care and the fact that
race is not biological
many attribute the beginnings of this
effort to medical students who openly
questioned the practice of race
adjustments during Medical School
lectures and began to call for the
removal of race from egfr equation
in 2019 this issue was prominently
highlighted in two major peer-reviewed
journals Jama and the clinical Journal
of the American Society of nephrology
who each published editorials
criticizing the use of race in kidney
function estimation
by early 2020 several prominent academic
institutions then announced that they
were no longer reporting race-based egfr
This Was Then followed in May of 2020 by
the murder of George Floyd which brought
forth heightened cries to enact broader
and more meaningful change to race-based
Medicine practices in general to address
Health Care disparities
so therefore due to the National
Spotlight on racial inequities and the
harm caused by race-based clinical
algorithms the Nephrology Community took
action
foreign
foundation and the American Society of
nephrology ended up partnering together
to announce the formation of a task
force in July of 2020 to critically
examine the use of race in GFR
estimation
they set forth to examine every aspect
of the inclusion of race in these
calculations
recognizing that changes in reporting
must consider multiple social and
clinical implications
they resolve to make recommendations
based on rigorous science and be
transparent to the public clinicians
laboratorians and other public health
officials in regards to potential
long-term implications of their
recommendations
at the same time in July of 2020 the
ckdfe research group led by doctors Andy
Levy and Leslie inker set forth to
reevaluate the existing CKD epic
creatinine based equation
with the purpose of establishing new
equations without a race parameter
cohort data used to initially derive the
original creatinine-based ckduppy
equations were re-analyzed with black
and non-black participants now grouped
into a single cohort to derive a single
equation rather than separating them
into individual cohorts with separate
equations
the new Race 3 equations were then
validated using a new data set that
combined cohort data from both old and
new research studies
after 10 months of meetings and
deliberation the nkf ASN task force
determined the best approach moving
forward with derivation of a single GFR
estimating equation without a race
parameter
derived from a racially diverse cohort
to be used for all patients
the task force was aware of the parallel
work by the CKD at the research group to
derive such an equation and in fact Dr
Leslie inker was on both the nkf ASN
task force and as part of the CKD Epi
research group
therefore CKD at the expedited their
analyzes and publication of their new
2021 equations
such that the task force final report
could directly recommend immediately
immediate implementation of their new
race-free equations
both documents were then published
online on September 23rd 2021.
the final task force recommendations are
outlined here
the first recommendation was to
immediately implement the new 2021 CKD
epi-creatinine equation that did not
have a race correction factor
the rationale for use of this equation
is that it does not include race
it includes diversity in its development
and is immediately available to all
clinical Labs since creatinine is a
widely used assay
Additionally the equation was shown to
have acceptable performance
characteristics
the second recommendation will be the
focus of the remainder of my talk
the task force recommended National
efforts to facilitate increased routine
and timely use of the Statin C
especially to confirm egfr based on
creatinine alone
the rationale
the Staten seat does not have observed
differences between race groups and
therefore the original
2012 the Statin C based CKD Epi equation
never had a race correction factor
additionally Studies have demonstrated
that Reliance on both creatine and
insistatency using the combined equation
provides the most accurate estimate of
egfr
and then lastly the task force third
recommendation
asks for more research on new biomarkers
for GFR estimation and also more
research on interventions to eliminate
race race and ethnic disparities
foreign
so if we are to so if we are to increase
use of the Statin C testing it's
important to understand the current
state of sustatancy assays and discuss
how best to implement more widespread
testing
first I will focus on the assays
themselves
an important issue to consider is the
Statin C assay standardization
as you would want results between
Laboratories to agree if all labs are
using a standard equation to estimate
GFR
standardization is achieved through
establishing traceability of methods to
reference procedures or reference
materials
there is a certified reference material
for Staten C that has been available
since 2010.
and this allows assay manufacturers to
calibrate their methods with the same
reference material to facilitate the
process of assay harmonization and
standardization
currently all major FDA approves the
Statin C manufacturers now have methods
traceable to the reference material
the last manufacturer established FDA
approved traceability in 2018.
so that has helped improve between
method agreement versus Statin C and
I'll be showing data regarding this in
the next slide
however there is no certified reference
method versus Statin C yet
therefore establishment of a reference
method should be prioritized to more
robustly established assay
standardization
the Improvement in substatency assay
performance over time is demonstrated in
this figure
these data are comparing results from
proficiency testing performed by cap
accredited Laboratories
these Laboratories tested a serum pool
collected from patients with known
chronic kidney disease shown in the left
panel
and they tested a serum pool collected
from healthy non-seekd donors
these two pools were tested in 2014 and
then they created two new pools in 2019
and repeated the testing
as you can see in the left panel for the
CKD serum pool in 2014 the four primary
sistatin C methods had quite a bit of
variability between methods and the
accuracy was mixed with some methods
within five percent of the target value
and others more than 20 percent off from
the target
there was a significant Improvement in
accuracy in between method agreement in
2019 as shown on the right side of this
first panel
with no method off by more than 10
percent from the Target in 2019 an all
message in the closer agreement with one
another
the same patterns are seen with the
healthy non-secaty serum pool shown in
the right-sided panel with an overall
Improvement in between method agreement
and accuracy from 2014 to 2019.
foreign
performance has significantly improved
and methods have an acceptable degree of
accuracy and agreement to support use
for GFR estimation
so the next question becomes how do we
support more widespread implementation
of
thank you Dr Carter for your informative
presentation
I'd now like to introduce our next
speaker Dr o Allison potok
Dr potak is currently funded by an NIH
Career Development k23 award
Dr potak was awarded the prestigious
American Kidney fund clinical scientists
in Nephrology research Grant in 2019
through 2021
her research focuses on understanding
the reasons why serum creatinine and
sistatin C May provide different
estimates of kidney function within the
same individual
she is also interested in tools used to
predict the progression of chronic
kidney disease
Dr potark you may now begin your
presentation
hi thank you for this kind presentation
and and thank you for having me
um so I I will be talking about the
clinical use of Statin c
um I have no disclosures
so the learning objectives will be to
understand what factors influence
creatinine and sustatancy serum levels
um to understand why it is important to
accurately estimate kidney function and
uh who should get consultancy measured
and to
understand how to interpret or try and
approach on how to to interpret
um when csatency GFR and creatinine GFR
give different results in the same
individual
so as Dr Carter mentioned the gold
standard to estimate or to actually know
somebody's kidney function is to measure
it but this is really difficult to do in
clinical practice especially in patients
who are hospitalized and are acutely
sick and need medications
um since the the measured GFR entails an
infusion of a substance such as inulin
or iohexal and measurements of blood
levels to determine the clearance so we
use endogenous markers such as
creatinine that has been used for
decades but creatinine is not a perfect
marker it's influenced by many factors
independent of kidney function such as
diets gender age muscle mass so
foreign
comes into play
um and we've been using sustatancy for a
few years now
um but since that and see is also not a
perfect marker and it's influenced by
different factors uh such as thyroid
function inflammation
certain drugs such as steroids obesity
cancer and so
um neither marker is is perfect but they
both provide some uh estimation of GFR
thank you
so why do we need to accurately estimate
GFR
one reason is medication dosing
because most
drugs or a lot of medications are
eliminated by the kidneys this is a
review that was done at the Mayo Clinic
on the prediction of renal elimination
of drugs with dissatency versus
creatinine
so this review looked at 28 articles
evaluating 16 different medications in
3455 participants
some medications came back multiple
times such as Vancomycin which is an
antibiotic very often used in
hospitalizations
in which we can measure the level in the
serum giving indication on on its
clearance and so overall this review
showed that egfrc Statin was more
predictive of drug levels and direct
clearance than any dfr creatinine
so we need to accurately
be able to estimate GFR for a lot of
medications
um since a majority of medications are
cleared by the kidneys eliminated by the
kidneys and
this includes antibiotics chemotherapy
where we want to make sure that we are
efficient with the dose that we're
giving but also not toxic and there's a
new class of drugs and clt2 Inhibitors
that have been shown to to slow down
progression of kidney disease and we
cannot give that to any patient it kind
of depends on the GFR so it's really
important to accurately be able to
estimate GFR
another reason to
accurately estimate GFR is for diagnosis
and prognosis purposes
um so this is the kdigo guidelines uh
heat map so the kidney disease improving
Global outcomes guidelines are followed
by American nephrologists and you can
see here the the classification of
chronic kidney disease based on GFR and
albuminuria
and so there are five uh classes
um classified being close to needing
dialysis close to kidney failure
um and so estimating GFR allows us to to
know in which uh class of CKD the
patient is
and also in the um to be able to give a
prognostic this is a kidney failure risk
equation and the QR code here will take
you to the website the kidney failure
risk equation was created by Dr tangri a
little more than a decade ago and it
includes age gender GFR and alduminuria
you can actually access it yourself on
this website and if you plug in those
four criteria it gives you an estimation
of your risk of end-stage kidney disease
in two years and five years
um and so knowing uh precisely what the
GFR is uh allows to have a better
estimation of this risk
who should we screen for kidney disease
and how to screen uh these are
um recommendations from experts at the
Kate Eagle controversies conference
and their conclusion was that we should
screen people with risk factors for
kidney disease including hypertension
diabetes cardiovascular disease
the weighted screen is using both
estimated GFR and alvuminuria and as far
as the estimated GFR goes we should
check both creatinine and cystatin to
have the best possible assessment of GFR
I just wanted to mention here that we
also check Imaging
when screening for for kidney disease
um this is a CAT scan of somebody who
has polycystic kidney disease you can
see here on both sides the kidneys are
really
big with a lot of cysts and that needs
Imaging to be diagnosed you could have a
slightly decreased GFR at the time of
diagnosis and some hematuria some other
in a family history
but you wouldn't be able to diagnose
without Imaging
so what do we do if the marketers don't
agree now that we have two different
markers we can calculate two different
gfrs and if they're different in the
same individual then how do we know
which one is more accurate
well it kind of depends it depends uh
what the person looks like
um I don't pretend that I know anything
about these two persons kidney function
but on the right hand side you have Mr
Arnold Schwarzenegger who is Young and
fit and has a pretty high muscle mass
and um I would expect uh in someone with
such a high muscle mass to have a high
serum creatinine
um but if we check into Staten C perhaps
uh the the GFR would look higher than
the one by creatinine
on the other side you have Mrs
jean-calmo who is a French lady who is
uh celebrating here her birthday she's
121 years old
and she looks a little bit frail and I
expect her muscle mass to be low and so
if you were to check uh creatinine level
in a in a frail old lady
um you would you could expect the
creatinine to be low not necessarily
because her kidney function is great but
because she doesn't have much muscle
mass and so if you check a cystatency
then perhaps you would have a more
accurate
estimation of her kidney function
this is actually the focus of my
research
um I've been looking at the difference
in egfr by system by creatinine in
various cohorts
and we constructed this difference so
that hire is better in the sense that we
would expect this difference to be
higher in people who are more fit and
younger and healthier in this difference
to be low in people who are frail and
and with low muscle mass and so this is
the distribution of this difference
so if the two markers are in agreement
the difference will be close to zero if
GFR sits that and has is very close to
GFR creatine then the difference will be
close to zero which is uh in the center
of this graph
and so we've been looking at this in
various cohorts this is an example of
one of the cohorts where we
um kind of artificially decided that if
the
um two gfrs are within 15 points of each
other
um we would consider that they're in
agreement and if there are more than 15
points different than it would be
um
different
so you can see here in the middle or
those who have egfr cystatin and egfr
creatinine that are within 15 points of
each other the green zone are those
where the GFR to Statin is higher than
the GFR Scranton by 15 points or more
and the red zone are those in whom the
gfrs is setting is lower than the GFR
creatinine by 15 points or more
so we would expect
um kind of people having a higher muscle
mass and being healthier to be in the
green zone
um and those who are more frail in and
less healthy to be in the red zone
and we actually
showed that those in the red zone are at
higher risk for Frailty
and at higher risk for hospitalizations
Falls cardiovascular disease and
mortality
the poor outcomes were associated with
uh with having a GFR cystatin being
lower than GFR creatinine by 15 points
or more
so then we asked ourselves if muscle
mass could explain this relationship
between the different egfrc Statin minus
egfr creatinine and Frailty is it is it
all explained by muscle and so we looked
at this in the health aging body
composition
study where we had measures of muscle
mass on Imaging on both CT scan and
dexis scan and we looked at the
relationship between this difference in
egfr and Trail C and we accounted for
several measures of muscle
um Imaging and so muscle mass on Imaging
which is muscle quantity and also we
adjusted for muscle quality using grip
strength and some measures of
physical activity and
um it doesn't explain it all so the the
relationship was attenuated but it
didn't completely go away which tells us
that muscle explains part of it but it
doesn't explain the entire relationship
so I wanted to go over a few clinical
scenarios where
um
the gfrs may not always be in agreement
to try and see how to approach it so
this is our first clinical scenario we
have a 56 year old Caucasian male with a
history of hypertension and type 2
diabetes for the past 10 years
um and he weighs 83 kilograms in his
last show uh serum creatinine level of
1.48 and his serum system C of 1.40
the question is does this patient does
this person have kidney disease and do
we need to do any workup
so we're going to calculate the gfrs to
be able to answer this question
so the egfr using creatinine with an old
equation was 52 with the new equation
was 55 this person is Caucasian so the
new equation without race the 2021 ckdfd
um so a GF egfr by creatinine slightly
higher
and then the egfr by systemc was 51 so
pretty much in agreement within you know
four points of each other
so looking at the heat map
um if if this was a chronic condition
meaning if if his serum creatinine and
cystatency had been stable for three
months or more we could
um
think that this patient has chronic
kidney disease and that would be stage
3A
and uh and so both GFR creatinine and
cystatin are agreeing on that
so
um he should probably get some work up
for that check uh the protein in the
urine to kind of quantify if he has any
proteinuria and also I would check an
A1c to assess how well controlled is his
diabetes
second case is a 70 year old Caucasian
female with hypertension who weighs 41
kilograms so kind of a tiny person and
her serum creatinine is 0.4
and her serum system C is 1.5
so
here is a scenario where if you look at
the serum creatinine you can guess that
the GFR is probably going to be quite
High
and indeed if we calculate the dfr
here's what we get the GFR by creatinine
whether we use the older the new
equation is more than 100 milliliters
per minute but if we check the cystatin
GFR it's actually 41.
so looking at the heat map here from the
cadigo guidelines her GFR creatinine is
is quite good so she wouldn't qualify to
have kidney disease based on that but if
we look at the systatin GFR she would
have CKD Sage 3B
um assuming this is steady state and and
chronic
so I would say that she most likely has
kidney disease and that her serum
creatinine is probably low because she's
a tiny old lady and probably doesn't
have much muscle mass and so she needs
further work up with checking urine for
protein and checking renal Imaging
our third case is a 44 year old
African-American male personal trainer
who weighs 95 kilograms
his serum creatinine is 1.55 and his
serums of Statin C is 0.95
to the F kidney disease and do we need
to do workouts
so if we calculate the gfrs we get
62 for creatinine GFR based on the old
equation 56
based on the new equation he's
African-American so the new equation
gets his GFR a little bit lower than the
old equation
with a base Factor
and looking at systatin GFR he's
actually at 89 so we we often see
referrals
uh for for patients who have high muscle
mass and are pretty young and healthy
and come to see us because the their
serum creatinine is on the high side and
if we take a cystat and see the GFR is
actually better so in his case uh should
we do any further work up
um I I would say yes just to You Know
cover our basis I would probably still
look at his urine and look at his
keeping Imaging but I'm not really
concerned
case four is a 56 year old Caucasian
woman with hypertension and depression
who presented with ostomyelitis of her
left thumb treated with IV vancomycin
and zosin and who was admitted with uh
acute kidney injury her serum creatinine
went from 1.0 to 11
.15 within three weeks so her GFR with a
cretinent of 11 is only six milliliters
per minute
the services checked and it's 1.98
leading to egfr since Statin of 32 so
you know quite better
and since you got Vancomycin uh we have
the advantage of being able to check a
level which also helps estimating the
kidney function
um as it gives a an indication on
clearance and so the Vancomycin random
level is 120.
thank you so this patient ended up
having a kidney biopsy this is a real
case and she had Vancomycin Associated
cast nephropathy
so the pathophysiology of Vancomycin
Associated cast nephropathy is still not
fully understood there's a couple
possible Pathways either the acute
kidney injury comes first from proximal
tubular injury and this leads to reduced
urine flow and cast formation
or maybe the cap formation starts first
from the increased Vancomycin
concentration which leads to
obstruction of the tubules which leads
to the acute kidney injury
so in this case
um I I think it's uh it's more likely
that the second High processes is the
right one I think it would explain why
the creatinine and the cystatency are so
widely different
the obstruction probably blocks the
creatinine excretion leading to a high
serum creatinine level so the
suspendency is reabsorbed and
metabolized by the proximal tubules and
this can still happen which explains why
the systatin sea level is lower
um in the GFR appears better when really
the the Vancomycin random level of 120
tells us that the kidney function is
very close to zero
um so there are a few scenarios where
um where this happens with the serum
creatinum being much higher than the
satin C
and this includes uh urinary obstruction
and reptomyolysis
as well
I hope these clinical scenarios were
helpful to to try and guide the
clinician as to how to approach a
problem where there's two widely
different egfrs in the same person I
think it's really helpful to check the
stat and see you know even if it's only
to confirm the creatinine based GFR at
least it kind of Comforts The clinician
that this is probably close to the true
kidney function if both estimates are an
agreement
um neither the creatinine nor the
statinency are perfect markers of kidney
function as we mentioned I think there
is really important clinical information
embedded in this difference in egfr by
systematic and creatinine and I
purposefully left out the combined
equation that includes creatinine and
sustainancy because I think it it just
pretty much provides an average of the
two separate gfrs but I think there's
information that is lost uh if we just
look at the average of the two
and and there's actually really
important information when we we look at
the two separately when they're rightly
different
and finally
um
having an egfr creatinine higher than
the gfrs Statin is associated with poor
outcomes cruelty hospitalizations
mortality
thank you I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you Dr potak for your informative
presentation now before we start our
live q a portion of the webinar I want
to pass the mic back over to Dr Karger
seemed as though there was a bit of a
technical difficulty that cut off the
last few slides of our presentation
I want to pass it over to you to provide
that final summary here
yes thanks so much so I can just
summarize what was at the end of my talk
since that was missing for those who are
watching this live
um so in the last part of my
presentation I was talking about some of
the barriers to Statin C testing uh the
main ones are the lack of widespread
availability of tests in-house versus
Staten C most clinical laboratories send
out versus Staten C testing which
obviously will slow down your turnaround
times
um and and not make that a result
available at the same time as a
creatinine based
egfr other barriers include cost so
Staten C remains significantly more
expensive than creatinine assays
um and then the other issue is the
availability on instrumentation so
creatinine is available on all sorts of
platforms big and small
um so statincy is just not as widely
available
um as creating and although there are
manufacturers who have moved to Staten C
onto more commonly used chemistry
instruments
um there's still a lot of Manufacturers
who don't have their own sister and C
assay and are relying on open Channel
cystatin C assays rather than developing
their own and so I think we need to have
more
manufacturers develop their own
sustatancy assays for their instruments
and so a couple strategies for
implementing cystatency I think number
one it's important to have uh clearer
guidance on clinical use and that's
something that continues to develop for
example the kdigo guidelines have not
been updated to
um uh match the new nkfasn Task Force
guidelines so I think those need to be
updated
um because those are now not in sync
with what the nkfasn task force has said
in terms of increasing use of Staten C I
think we also need to prioritize
placement assistance see on more
platforms like creatinine if we want to
see it used more widely and then I think
a really important step that can be
taken by nephrologist is to engage their
Clinical Laboratory directors
and try to get testing in-house in more
locations and also for nephrologist to
provide education to Providers if that
testing is brought in-house as to how to
use a stat and C
and then lastly if we can get better
reimbursement and lower costs for this
the system.cs assay I think that will
also Aid in implementation
great well thank you Dr Karger for
reiterating that and summarizing those
last few slides there now um to our
audience I'd like to welcome everyone to
participate in our live q a session
so as a reminder if you have a question
that you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is for you Dr Karger
um this question says you mentioned that
sustatancy is traditionally performed on
immunoassay instruments but more
recently that manufacturers have been or
excuse me have made versions available
on clinical chemistry instruments could
you please discuss some of the
differences Runnings the statins see on
these different platforms
yeah thanks so much for this question so
I alluded to this a minute ago that
um traditionally sister and see has been
run in more specialized Laboratories but
some manufacturers have put the assay on
the clinical chemistry instruments that
are in uh more Laboratories and acute
care laboratory settings
um and are more make the testing more
widely available
um in terms of the differences in
running it in a specialized lab versus a
chemistry on a chemistry platform
comparisons between assays have shown
that they agree pretty well now that
manufacturers have harmonized assays to
the reference material that I mentioned
in my talk
um and so the between method agreement
is pretty good there's always room for
improvement and I think if we can get
the reference method that would push us
even further towards better
harmonization
um but basically the main benefit of
having it on those chemistry instruments
is that it provides the opportunity for
more labs to bring into statins because
those specialized amino acid instruments
are only going to be available at
academic institutions or send out
um a Reference Laboratory so that's the
main benefit of it being on those
different types of platforms is more
availability
great thank you my next question here is
for Dr potalk and this is a two-part
question here so this asks any thoughts
or guidance on how to make the
transition from egfr creatinine to egfr
systatin less challenging for clinicians
and could you speak a little more to the
re-baselining of patients
uh hi yes
um so I think
um it is going to be challenged
challenging for uh clinicians to move
from one to the other like you know like
everything new uh you need to get used
to it and get comfortable with it
um so I think the more we use the stat
and see the the more comfortable we'll
be using it and trying to understand you
know in in which settings it's it
provides a different GFR from creatinine
I I don't think that there is actually a
re-baselining of patients meaning you
know we've been using creatinine for a
very long time and we can usually follow
the trend over time of of what the
creatinine level is and we've been using
in some places to sat and see for a much
shorter period of time and so if if you
follow a patient in his creatinine level
has been quite stable for several years
and it provides you a you know given GFR
let's say I don't know 40 and then you
text the sentencing it provides a GFR of
25. it doesn't mean that this patient's
kidney function dropped that day it just
means that now we have a new marker well
it provides you a different answer as to
what the GFR is in you know the question
is which which one should we trust but I
think it's reassuring is that creatinine
level has been stable for several years
that we know the kidney function has
been the same for at least that period
of time and just having this new marker
well we maybe need to be a little bit
more careful with dosing of medications
and and try to understand why we get
different values but I I don't think
that it means this patient's kidney
function changed you know
I hope that answers the question
great thank you our next question here
is for Dr Karger this question asks the
nkf ASN Task Force guidelines
recommended more widespread use of
Statin C but didn't provide a lot of
details regarding how to incorporate it
into clinical care do you recommend
waiting for additional guidance from
Nephrology societies before we Dive In
that's a great question I actually think
we're under utilizing the Staten C even
based on outdated guidelines so for
example in the 2012 kdo guidelines they
do say assistancy should be used to
confirm
uh egfr when the creatinine based
estimate is in question or if you're you
know at a cut Point
um for diagnosing a patient or you know
your border between different stages of
CKD or between CKD or not CKD
um you know encourages Staten C is an
alternative and what we're seeing is
really it's very very underutilized even
based on those old guidelines I do
anticipate that there is going to be
more granular
um and clear guidance coming forth in
the next couple of years based on uh the
nkfas and task force recommendations to
use this biomarker more
um but I think it's fine to jump in and
encourage providers to use it now
educate providers on it I think it's
good to have maybe a slow ramp up and
make them aware of this as an
alternative and especially for those
patients who have uh factors that would
affect the accuracy of creatinine based
estimation for example those on the
extremes of muscle mass you really
shouldn't be using a creatinine base
estimate you should really be looking at
to Staten C so there's there's a lot of
opportunities now to use it and then we
should just keep an eye on what those
future guidelines are going to be and we
can always evolve uh our use based based
on the future guidance
great thank you
all right I have another question here
again for Dr potalk how do you think
sistatin C might affect referrals to
nephrology
I think it will probably increase
referral to Nephrology and that's okay
um I think you know in in my institution
at the University of California San
Diego and at the VA
um we have been using the Statin C for a
few years now and and try to check in
our clinics and on the inpatient setting
also and it's it's not always easy to to
understand why we get different GFR
values so we actually have a little
console service Among Us nephrologists
and I get a lot of you know text or
emails from my colleagues with questions
on how to interpret and what to do and I
again I think the more we use it and the
more the more comfortable we'll be using
it and and it's okay if if we get more
referrals for a while until people
understand how to use the stat and see
and how to interpret the results
great thank you all right
next question here do you recommend
reporting egfr based on sustatancy alone
or egfr based on both creatinine and to
Staten C in the combined equation or
both
yeah this that's a great question as to
how to implement this and which
equations to report I think in the
future in an ideal situation we would
actually report a trio of estimates a
creatinine based estimate assistant C
alone based estimate and then the
combined estimate and why I think having
all three is important Dr potak alluded
to this earlier having the individual
Crown in the system see estimates allows
you to see if there's a major
discrepancy between the two so you want
that information to see
um and to really inform you as to
whether maybe there's an issue affecting
the patient's creatinine or Society
that's not GFR related so you can
identify which of the two estimates is
most accurate in terms of
um uh estimating their kidney function
but why should we report the combined
equation and this alludes to one of the
questions that was asked
also in terms of you know data comparing
all the equations data has shown that
the most accurate estimate is the one
that relies on both biomarkers together
this is Statin C plus creatinine
equation so if you have all three
equations and they all are in relatively
good agreement then you could rely on
that combined equation as as the most
accurate estimate if however you see the
three estimates and you see that the
creatinine substancy don't agree with
each other they're very discrepant you
shouldn't use the combined estimate
because it's averaging the two you
should look at the two creatinine alone
is hysterency alone and really think
about what about this patient could be
affecting either the accuracy of the
sounds or the accuracy the creatinine so
for example if there are heavy smoke or
we know smoking impacts of Statin C
accuracy so then you'd want to just rely
on creatinine only and not the combined
equation so that's why all three
equations can be useful for really
figuring out what what the kidney
function of the patient is
wonderful
well thank you Dr Karger and Dr potak
again for your time today in your
informative presentation
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you had provided at
the time of registration
so we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Siemens health and ears
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
and elaborates will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye